Wohin du auch immer gehst,
Nimm mich mit!
Ich bin deine Frau, die
immer auf deiner Seite ist.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass
sie die Erste ist, die heiratet.
Aber es ist schön,
es ist lustig.
Die mittlere Schwester hat
zuerst Kinder, die jüngere ....
... Schwester heiratet und
ich komme dann jetzt hinterher.
Schöne Beine. Emil.
Das sagst du bei jedem.
Er versteht es gut mit den
Frauen. Er versteht mich.
Was heisst das?
Er weiss, was ich essen oder
trinken möchte.
Ich kann sagen: Ich will oder
auch einmal, ich will nicht.
Als Beistand oder als Vormund
muss man die Einwilligung geben.
Als ich den Eindruck hatte, dass
die beiden wirklich heiraten ...
... wollen, haben sie meine
Einwilliugng sofort erhalten.
Es gibt etwas Feines zum Essen,
ein grosses Fest.
Weil ich sie einfach liebe und
dies unser Wunsch war.
Julia und Remo hätten auf dem
Standesamt heiraten dürfen ...
... mit der Zusage des Vormunds.
Bei Julia sind das die Eltern.
Sie hätten das auch gemacht,
wenn die IV-Rente dann nicht ...
... einfach gekürzt worden wäre.
Das heisst, sie würden nur ...
... anderthalb Mal statt
zweifach eine Rente erhalten.
Das macht für sie keinen Sinn.
Oh, du siehst aber schön aus.
Du bist ein Schlitzohr.
Der Staat hat Rechtshoheit ...
... und wir als Kirche können
keinen Rechtsakt vollziehen.
Wenn die Ziviltrauung nicht
vorausgegangen ist, ...
... dürfen wir das als
Kirche nicht Hochzeit nennen.
Darum habe ich statt Trauung
das Wort Einsegnung verwendet.
Ich selbst als Pfarrer. Das ist
eine Art Abmachung ...
... zwischen Staat und Kirche.
Und für den lieben Gott?
Vor Gott und wenn man das
spirituell anschaut ...
... gibt es da vielleicht
gar keinen Unterschied.
Und dann kleben wir
den Bauch hierhier.